[Musik]
es muss uns klar sein dass alles was
positives in der region passiert aber
auch alles negative natürlich auch einen
bumerang effekt haben kann in österreich
und in der gesamten eu die größte
herausforderung für meine persönliche
arbeit und für mein persönliches
forschungsgebiet liegt darin die
richtigen fragen zu stellen und es
ermöglicht zu bekommen darauf auch nur
annähernd korrekte antworten zu finden
ich bin immer wieder überrascht wie
viele konflikte die als vermeintlich
moderne konflikte da stehen eigentlich
vorläufer konflikte haben die
jahrhunderte alt sind ich denke dass es
dass es wichtig ist dass man selbst
bestimmt unterschiedliche orte suchen
kann dass man riecht fühlt und schmeckt
wie sich die region anfühlt
ich sehe als ein wesentliches element
von friedenssicherung
die eingrenzung von
feindbildern
bzw
auch
das bloßstellen von feindbildern
[Musik]
ein forscher ist für mich persönlich
jemand der unglaubliches interesse
an ungelösten problemen hat er muss froh
darüber sein jeden abend mit mehr fragen
nach hause zu gehen als er in der früh
mit fragen gekommen ist der oder die
müssen für das thema brennen müssen sich
interessieren und ich glaube alles
andere ist erlernbar letztlich geht es
darum der wahrheit auf den grund zu
gehen
auch wenn man als wissenschafterin genau
weiß wahrheit bleibt immer relativ
[Musik]
militärische und zivile expertise
gebündelt in einem institut dem institut
für friedenssicherung und
konfliktmanagement der
landesverteidigungsakademie kurz gfk
leidenschaft für sicherheitspolitik das
ist es was uns alle am fk verbindet wir
stellen das risikobild für österreich
wir analysieren die europäische
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik und
wir betreiben grundlagenforschung zur
geistigen landesverteidigung
somit ist das
sicherheitspolitische kompetenz zentrum
für konfliktforschung und neue risiken
dabei konzentrieren wir uns regional auf
den westbalkan afrika den nahen und
mittleren osten sowie russland und
osteuropa aktuell bauen wir aber auch
unsere china kompetenz aus wir
beurteilen die aktuellsten entwicklungen
im krisen management und ziehen
schlussfolgerungen für das
österreichische bundesheer und die
internationalen einsätze ein weiterer
fokus unserer tätigkeit liegt auf
hybriden bedrohungen und terrorismus
sowie cyber sicherheit und entwicklung
neuer technologien am fk forschen wir
also in sehr viele richtungen stärken
dabei kontinuierlich unser
internationales forschungsnetzwerk und
eröffnen die jungen forschern
einstiegschancen in das faszinierende
welt der sicherheitspolitik aufgrund
dieser breit aufgestellten
forschungsarbeit genießen wir aber auch
das vertrauen vom parlament
bundeskanzleramt und anderen ministerien
verständnis für immer komplexere
sicherheits zusammenhänge ist
voraussetzung für staatliche und
individuelle krisenvorsorge daher
informieren wir sie mit einer aktiven
medien und öffentlichkeitsarbeit denn je
unsicherer die zeiten desto wichtiger
ist eine professionelle
sicherheitspolitische analyse und
beratung unser motto wer frieden und
sicherheit will muss konflikte und
risiken verstehen
das ziel dass ich mit meiner arbeit
erreichen möchte ist zu implementieren
dass die welt nicht schwarz weißes zu
implementieren dass es multi spektrale
problemfelder sind die auch von
unterschiedlichen akteuren
unterschiedlich gesehen werden und
letztendlich das eigentlich ein
verständnis dafür zu treffen ist was
alles sehr kompliziert für mich ist sehr
wichtig die erfahrungen die ich vor ort
in einsatz regionen gemacht habe nicht
nur zu teilen sondern auch etwas
zurückzugeben und eines davon ist zb ein
ziviles engagement bei der österreich
afghanistan gesellschaft wo man auch die
eigene expertise
einbringen kann in projekte vor ort und
hier brach das operative dort bewegen
kann das besondere am fh sind seine
mitarbeiter wenn wir uns auch nur
zwischendurch treffen ist der immer ein
sehr intensiver gedankenaustausch
gedankenaustausch wo jeder seine hohe
akademische bildung einbringen seine
erfahren durch reisen und seine
jahrelange erfahrung durch die
beschäftigung mit den jeweiligen themen
[Musik]